La volta al món a peu, dia 240.
Fa vent, fa vent i per això estic a dintre de la tenda i porto les ulleres de sol
perquè no em veieu la cara de adormit.
Si estigués a fora de la tenda sentiríeu el micro.
Bueno, al final no ha passat res, no ha passat res, no ha vingut ningú
i la tenda ha aguantat perfectament.
Hi ha hagut ratxes fortes de vent
i a vegades feia aquest soroll
però bé, bé, he dormit bé i la tenda no s'ha mogut.
No, no, no, molt bé, molt bé, molt bé.
Primera prova de vent amb aquesta tenda que he tingut
i l'he passat amb nota.
El Pamir farà molt més vent
i bueno, com a mínim, de moment, aquesta l'ha aguantat bé.
Ara a recollir, que és la pitjor part del dia
i continuo caminant.
El Pamir farà molt més vent
He parat aquí a fer un Turkish Coffee
i a gravar el que va passar ahir, si us en recordeu.
Si vau veure el vídeo d'ahir, sabeu que hi ha unes parts
que no van quedar gravades.
I l'he fet ara.
És un lloc que està aquí al costat de la carretera.
He fet 4 quilòmetres i res, a seguir.
He parat ara a una espècie de supermercat
per fer una cosa.
Perquè tenien lavabo, posava.
I sí, sí, sí, lavabo amb tassa.
Molt benvingut.
El supermercat en si no té absolutament res.
Té alcohol, patates fregides i dolços.
Tot prohibit.
L'altre dia us vaig parlar del tema de l'ultrasons,
que no el portava i em vaig oblidar d'explicar-vos el per què.
Doncs aquí el tenim.
Des del dia que vaig arribar a Bojormi, no funciona.
Mireu, aquí hauria d'activar-se la llum vermella
i no s'activa.
He intentat canviar la bateria perquè en tenia una altra pila de recanvi
i no, no, tampoc, tampoc.
No sé si es va humitejar.
L'he obert, perquè tinc aquí com una espècie de tornavís.
L'he obert i no està humit ni res.
Em sembla que està tot bé.
Per tant, no sé per què.
No sé per què posa espatllat.
Per tant, procediré a llançar-lo ara mateix.
M'ha fet servei, eh?
M'ha fet servei.
I bueno, espero, jo intueixo,
que a partir d'ara, a partir de Uzbekistan, de Tajikistan,
ja el necessitaré.
Potser a l'Índia m'hauria anat bé, saps?
Però també és veritat que a la frontera amb la Xina
no sé si l'havés passat, saps?
Potser l'havés tirat abans de la frontera amb la Xina
perquè, bueno, a la Xina som sensibles en determinades coses.
Per exemple, no pots portar un ganivet.
No pots portar un ganivet a la Xina.
Val?
Llavors, doncs, bueno, potser l'haig llançat.
Per tant, res.
Bé, avui...
Avui és l'últim dia d'Ultraman.
La carretera fa molta corba cap allà.
Si retallo per aquí, vaig més ràpid.
Em trobo enmig d'un petit bosquet al costat de la carretera
perquè ara m'han de trucar de RAC1, del món a RAC1 d'estiu.
I, bueno, aquests de la ràdio ja se sap que a vegades
van endarrerits o el que sigui
i porto com 15 minuts esperant.
Estic enmig del bosc perquè fa bastant de vent,
però dintre del bosc, doncs, està més protegit del vent.
No bufa tant perquè els arbres paren.
Avui estic caminant molt poc, eh?
Són la una i vint i porto 13 quilòmetres només.
Les tres i disset.
Pujant, pujant, a poc a poc, per aquesta carretera tan escènica.
Si jo fos moter o m'agradés conduir cotxes
i m'agradés anar per carreteres xules,
aquesta seria una de les que vindria.
Perquè els passatges són molt guapos.
Estàs a prop de la capital, la Tbilisi,
i molt bé.
Bueno, avui es veu ja l'herba menys verda,
més seca.
Ens anem apropant a Tbilisi, anem baixant de cota.
Bueno, anem pujant, eh?
I molt tranquil.
Avui hi havia la possibilitat d'anar per la carretera principal
i després d'esviar-me per un camí
fins a enganxar-me a aquesta carretera,
potser sí anar tot per carretera
perquè no vull arriscar-me un altre cop a gossos i històries serbs.
Vaig tranquil per aquí.
Algú diria, ostres, l'asfalt no et fa mal els peus i les articulacions?
Doncs no tant, eh?
Jo crec que sí que em feia mal al principi
quan no estava tan acostumat a portar tants quilòmetres i a caminar,
però ara vaig bastant bé.
També vaig més lleuger de la motxilla,
llavors clar, l'impacte és menor.
Molt important anar lleuger.
Porto una bona estona sense parar.
Són les cinc.
I veig aquí una cosa.
No sé què és.
Veig cotxes.
Normalment, quan hi ha bastants cotxes, vol dir que venen alguna cosa.
El que passa és que aquí no sé què pot haver-hi
perquè estem al mig del nord, eh?
Em vaig a apropar-me a veure què és.
Buah!
Sembla un lloc que donen de menjar, eh?
És un salve a la vida, eh?
Perquè no he dinat, bueno, he menjat una quarta xorrada de fruits secs i res,
però menjar, de veritat, no.
El que passa és que són les cinc.
No sé si hi haurà alguna cosa.
Només tenint una cosa de menjar, però ja m'està bé
perquè és una cosa de la cuina georgiana
que encara no havia provat.
No recordo el nom.
M'ho he dit dues vegades.
Està omplert de carn.
És com una empanada, o una empanada gallega.
I aquí, en aquest entorn tan maco,
amb la bandera aquí a l'ombra,
amb l'aigua amb gas, ja,
que m'he absolutament viciat.
Estic complint el repte, eh?
Estic complint.
No us vaig parlant tant, però...
L'únic moment que costa és quan entres al supermercat
i veus coses dolces o refrescs
que llavors dius
me'n menjaré un gelat ara, i no puc.
Però, bueno, només queden 24 hores
per poder començar
a inflar-me de dolços una altra vegada.
Sí, ho faré.
Ha assegut el voral de la carretera
gairebé les set.
Set, no?
Ja són les set de la tarda.
Menjar una poma infecta d'aquestes georgianes.
No tenen la millor fruita en aquest país.
He anat al supermercat
a comprar aigua, a vestir-me una mica
per la nit.
No sé per què ara això m'ha entrat al baixón.
Avui és un dia que ha passat tot
molt ràpid
i no ha passat absolutament res.
Només caminant per la carretera,
l'entrevista a RAC1, i ja són les set, tu.
Bueno, està bé.
A veure el que diu.
Les vuit i divuit.
Espectacular, presta de sol.
Llàstima de no haver campat abans
per veure, poder-te veure més plenament.
I aquest lloc és brutal.
Té unes vistes increïbles.
Hi ha unes cages aquí darrere meu
que estan a mig construït.
No estan al mapa,
Bueno, si estan a més construir no hi haurà veïns, val?
El lloc que he proposat jo, a mi mateix, és aquesta muntanyeta d'aquí.
Està molt exposada al vent i està molt exposada a les vistes, especialment dels cotxes que venen per allà.
Però, bueno, investigarem.
El lloc és idíl·lic, eh? Completament pla, herba baixa i les vistes brutals.
Però, o sigui, és veritat que no hi ha manera que no em vegin a la carretera, eh?
He intentat amagar, o sigui, ajupir-me així una mica, però no, no, no, no.
I cap allà fa massa baixada i no està pla. Per tant, res.
Per tant, o escollir un altre lloc o em quedo aquí.
Vull mirar un cotxe.
Un cotxe que es desvia.
Es desvia cap aquí.
Bueno, per aquí és gairebé impossible pujar, eh?
Per la pujada que he fet a peu.
És per un 4x4 i 4x4 bèstia.
Bueno.
Jo diria que em quedo, tu. Em quedo.
Vale, he parlat massa ràpid. Està pujant per aquí, el cotxe aquest.
A veure.
Llamar jove.
No res. Al final hi ha una família que venia a fer la foto i ja està.
Han marxat.
Bueno, sí, sí, he acampat aquí. Les vistes sensacionals. Sensacionals.
També dintre la tenda. Ara mateix.
M'ha costat trobar el lloc, eh?
El lloc en el qual tenir el cap més elevat que els peus i a la vegada poder tenir vistes cap allà.
Però l'he trobat, l'he trobat.
Avui, 39 km i pico i gairebé 800 metres de desnivell positiu.
Prou bé, prou bé.
Un cafè. He parlat amb una persona.
Refrescos cap i gastats 30 euros.
Per aquí he comprat una cosa que no us he dit, que és...
Un altre powerbank.
Sí, l'he comprat per dos motius. També el cable.
He comprat un cable tipo USB-A.
Hi ha dos motius.
Un és que a la carretera del Pamir al Tajikistan jo crec que hi haurà un espai bastant gran entre llocs de càrrega.
I, bueno, amb una bateria estic més tranquil.
És de 10.000, és més lleugera. Tot pesa, tot pesa.
Però, bueno, crec que necessitaré.
I dos, la placa solar l'he estat provant aquests dies i m'està donant problemes amb la bateria gran, la de 20.000.
Bueno, pel que he estat buscant per internet, podria ser que el fet que la bateria solar doni molt poc amparatge
fa que tingui problemes a encarregar-se.
I el que passa és que, de cop i volta, en una hora,
carrega el 30%.
I dic jo, això és impossible.
És impossible que aquesta plaqueta solar en una hora carregui el 30%.
Llavors intento carregar el mòbil des de la bateria gran
i el que hauria de ser un 10% de descàrrega és un 30 o un 40%.
Això vol dir que no està carregat correctament i aquest 30% és fals, no?
I, bueno, buscant, buscant, podria ser que el powerbank aquest no admetés aquest tipus de corrent.
No ho tinc molt clar.
Però potser un powerbank més petit sí.
Ho provaré.
De fet, avui he estat provant amb la placa solar i sembla que funciona millor amb aquesta.
O sigui, amb la placa solar carregant aquesta bateria.
Hauré de fer més proves, igualment.
Hauré de fer més proves, a veure què tal.
I això és tot. Demà acaba la meva travessa íntegrament a peu.
Demà arribo a Tbilisi.
I el dia 31 agafo un avió.
Però, clar, demà és com...
Vale, he arribat des de Barcelona fins aquí, a peu, sense agafar cap avió.
És demà.
Cosa que, bueno, estaria més nerviós si no fos perquè ja he estat a Tbilisi diverses vegades.
Llavors, bueno, no hi ha tanta emoció.
Per cert, avui, trunyaco de vídeo.
Ho sé, en sóc conscient. Em sap greu.
No hi puc fer més perquè, mira, ha sigut un dia que no ha passat res.
Després d'uns dies de moltes emocions.
I sense el micro és complicat gravar.
Excuses, excuses, excuses.
Però bueno, ja m'ho perdonareu, vinga.
Bona nit.